in the early 1980s Cold War tensions are
rising America's new President Ronald
Reagan has given the military one
priority challenge the Soviets
everywhere the Navy really wasn't
interested in website Anna I had to
build a whole thought process a logic of
why the Navy should fund me to do what I
want to do and the only reason I could
convince them to do that is if I did
what they wanted me to do this Ballard's
pitch the video technology he is
building to find Titanic can also gather
intelligence on the ocean floor American
or Soviet I'm a geologist I'm an
underwater mapper and I go into unknown
terrain and I map it and then I collect
things from it to the Navy it's not
mapping and sampling it's it's searching
finding and recovering lost things so
they have a great interest in the same
technology the Navy generally peers into
the ocean depths with sonar a technique
that finds an object by bouncing
soundwaves off of it but sonar can't
tell a rock from a hunk of metal
Ballard's cameras will deliver the
clearest images the Navy's ever had of
even the smallest debris
the Admiral is impressed of course its
technology was valuable well the ocean
is littered with all kinds of
interesting intelligence I can tell you
Admiral thunman won't send Ballard to
hunt Titanic but he wants him to revisit
a pair of tragedies that shook the Navy
deeply in the 1960s the loss of two
top-secret nuclear submarines both were
attack subs fast quiet boats built to
hunt down their Soviet counterparts the
first the thresher sank in 1963 with a
hundred and twenty-nine aboard the
second the Scorpion disappeared in 1968
with the loss of 99 they were America's
worst submarine disasters since World
War two and the Navy investigated them
thoroughly but was limited by its tools
now it wants to see what more Ballard
and his high-tech eyes can uncover with
the Cold War on dollard's expedition
must be kept secret we didn't want
Soviet Union to find those submarines we
didn't want them to go to the thresher
and Scorpion and Oh Graham Ballard will
conduct thorough surveys of the two
sunken subs hunt for further evidence of
what sank them and find their nuclear
reactors Ballard signs on to the
clandestine operation if he gets
something in return I saw a look that's
fair enough but if there's any time left
over I would like to take that extra
time
and look for the Titanic the Navy will
fund Ballard's equipment and he'll get
time once his secret missions are done
to hunt Titanic do whatever you want
just don't spend any more money probably
should have done that sworn into active
duty Robert Ballard becomes the US
Navy's newest undercover agent whose
brief is the ocean floor